again i have a quadratic in cos theta
but it's a little bit messier okay so
i've got
okay now i'll just take this opportunity
to
um illustrate to you the method that i
sort of
was trying to show you at the end of
last lesson but wrongful happened or
that kind of thing
which i think is on par with pairing up
terms because this is
not harmonic there's not a one out the
front so how would i approach this
i'm looking for well i should put this
all in
one line on one side first so
i'll have minus two here and now i can
solve this
okay what i'm searching for is a pair of
numbers that adds up to
five and
multiplies to minus six
negative six right multiplies negative
six
adds to five what are the pair of
numbers
i think it's going to be 6 and negative
1
right because 6 and negative 1
they'll give me 5 right and 6 times
negative 1
will give me minus 6 which is what i was
looking for okay
so the way i put that into this equation
is a little bit funny so watch okay um
i'm going to double up on something and
then remove it so i'm going to have 3
cos theta plus 6 3 cos
theta minus 1 and then i'm going to
divide by 3.
okay now what have i done so this is
kind of like a parallel method
i kind of like this because it makes
clear where these numbers come from it's
just like factoring harmonic one
with this additional thing considered
okay
and then this factorization is really
clear and it's easy to work with
algebraically
if i've chosen my numbers right you
notice i've got threes here and here but
i shouldn't should i
okay because if i multiply these two
together i'll get
9 cos squared theta not 3 right so
that's why i divide by 3 to take that
into account and if i've chosen my
numbers right
that 3 should go into one of these and
you can see which one
right so i'm gonna have cos theta plus
two three cos theta minus one
and now i can solve does that make sense
okay so i'm going to branch off again
branch what value should cos theta take
to do the left-hand factor
i'll ask the question again what value
should cos theta take
in order to solve the left-hand factor
minus two
okay i'll come back to that in a second
i'm going to write both of the solutions
to the factors for this side
i should have cos theta equals a third
i said one over three okay and you can
just mentally chuck that in there like
three times a third minus one
zero okay so i've written down what
would be required to solve each of these
and now i approach them now cos theta
equals negative two what's the
range vertically of cos theta from
what's the bottom value minus one to one
so
this is outside that range right so i
can say therefore
no real solution that's an r with
two vertical lines okay it stands for
real
no real solution this thing is not going
to contribute at all
that's it so now i just do this one over
three
it's not an exact value so you're going
to need to reach for your calculator on
this one
you could think okay first and fourth
quadrant right so it'll be some angle
theta
and then 360 minus theta we wanna why
don't we do um
let's do nearest minute shall we so i
think it's going to be like 70 something
degrees 32 minutes it's worth mentioning
as well
that when you get your number here right
you also have a number here
and that's you know degrees minutes
seconds
right just like normal minutes and
seconds there are only
60 minutes in a degree and only 60
seconds
in a minute right so for instance this
was 31
it would round up not down you gotta
watch out for that one that's very
tricky
okay so that's one of the angles that's
the acute angle
i'll need the reflex angle which is 360
minus that which is
189 degrees 28 thank you
there you go so
that's what i've got this doesn't
contribute to any solutions
this contributes those i'm done okay
now have a look at three i'm gonna stop
talking for a sec
but i will tell you i'll give you a bit
of a nudge in the right direction what's
different between two and three
there are two well there's one variable
but there's two
functions aren't there right like these
are both quadratics in cos
but this is not a quadratic in sign and
it's not a quadratic in cause
either so we've got to make it into one
of those in order to solve that okay
what piece of knowledge do we have that
we can use in this situation
okay so both of you are right okay so
the basic
piece you need is the pythagorean
identity
right sine squared plus cos squared is
equal to one and clearly
you can kind of rearrange that a little
bit if you've got a sine square
and you want to substitute that for
something else you just move the cos
squared over the other side
right or if in reverse you want to turn
it into all
causes right sorry all signs
instead of going that way you could move
the science square over the other side
and get this right so these are all the
pythagorean identities just different
forms of them yeah but so why would you
change the cause
if you had a different question so if
for instance it was two cos squared plus
sign
then you would change it all in terms of
signs right so we can change them when
they're squared
but it's a bit finicky to change it when
it's just a single
linear linear function
you